[Musik]
ihr kennt das doch sicherlich auch ihr
habt gerade ein fantastisches mal hinter
euch ihr fühlt euch voll wenn nicht
sogar überfressen doch dann kommt jemand
mit kuchen daher und ihr denkt durch so
wie kommt es dass wir manchmal weiter
und weiter essen und wo wir kurz vorm
platzen sind er war vielleicht wie
funktioniert appetit eigentlich sobald
unser magen leer ist wird ein hormon
namens green ausgeschüttet das uns ein
verlangen nach essen spüren lässt
deswegen oft hunger hormon genannt
greift der name teilweise ein bisschen
zu kurz krines gewissermaßen auch ein
strässer wohnen das uns ausdauernd
willenskraft in der schweren situation
verleiht der schickt ja okay wenn wir
noch etwas zu futtern bekommen sinkt der
green spiegel und ein anderes hormon
betritt die bühne nämlich leptin die
rolle von leptin ist es uns zu sagen
unser körper ist also eigentlich mit
einem perfekten kontrollen mechanismus
ausgestattet der uns sagt wann wir essen
und wann wir aufhören soll
wieso bitten wir dann trotzdem andere
menschen und die chipstüte weg zu nehmen
weil wir uns selbst nicht kontrollieren
können essen das viel fett und oder
zucker beinhaltet empfinden wir als
besonders schmackhaft weil es uns
besonders viel energie liefert bei
unseren vorfahren macht es noch sinn
dass der körper besonders energiereiche
nahrung als ich besonders begehrenswert
empfand zu zeiten der jäger und sammler
quasi tag mittag ums überleben kämpfen
musste heute kann man sich vor fett und
zuckerhaltige lebensmittel kaum retten
da haben wir immer wieder den
klassischen fall dass sich unsere umwelt
schneller verändert hat als unsere
evolution wissenschaftler sprechen
manchmal von hedonistischen hunger der
vergleichbar impulsiv sollen sollen wie
drogenkonsum oder glücksspiele bei fett
und zuckerhaltigen lebensmitteln werden
endorphine und dopamin ausgeschüttet
die für euphorie sorgen und das
belohnungssystem gespielt so können
andere hormonelle signale die mit dem
sättigungsgefühl zusammenhängen
untergraben werden die mehr zucker und
fetthaltige lebensmittel wir essen desto
eher besteht die gefahr dass wir
gegenüber unseren körpereigene hormon
antworten abstumpfen die regulierung
durch gremien und leptin wird immer
ineffektiver wodurch wir immer mehr junk
food essen teufelskreis im umkehrschluss
heißt es allerdings dass wir um so
weniger junkfood verlangen die weniger
wird davon ist macht hoffnung oder schön
schlau wie geht es euch seid ihr auch
hedonistische esser oder habt ihr
vielleicht oder gute tipps wie man der
schokotorte oder der chipstüte
widerstehen kann
schreibe es in die kommentare zusammen
mit euren fragen wir sehen uns nächstes
mal